[Music]
here's what I have experienced in 30
years of financial coaching and in my
personal experience with the guy in my
mirror we all have a drama queen in us
every one of us and when we want
something the drama queen takes the form
of a four-year-old kid on the cereal
aisle throwing a fit never seen that kid
his little face gets red and he demands
cereal or his life is coming to an end
and the biggest mistakes I have made
with money and the biggest mistakes I
have observed you guys out there make
with money is when you use some noble
high calling like your marriage or your
children or adoption or in vitro or
fill-in-the-blank taking care of my
special needs child some unbelievably
very important high calling and you use
that in your emotions I've used it in my
emotions in drama-queen mode to box
myself into two possible decisions with
money one serves the purpose of the
nobility takes care of the child serves
the marriage whatever it is and the
other one serves money and so you put
yourself in this false dichotomy that
says I it the only way to not choose
money over my family is to choose this
stupid financial choice and so I'm
having my third child we don't have room
for a car seat I have a $4,000 Honda so
I go in buy a $45,000 SUV I was forced
to buy that car for the good of my
children they would not have been safe
they're wise have you ever had that call
on this show if you've been listening a
show for a while you've heard that call
I've taken that call a hundred times
in the last two years a hundred times I
was forced to do something for the good
of my child
that is absolutely freaking ludicrous
and stupid but because of my drama queen
self has boxed myself into a corner I am
forced to do something that is
absolutely freaking makes Congress look
smart I mean it's just stupid on
steroids I'm forced to do something that
is dumb dumb dumb with money oh but it's
okay because it's for adoption oh but
it's okay because it's for in-vitro oh
but it's okay the child has special
needs oh but it's okay it's to be with
my son oh but my marriage wouldn't have
survived if I hadn't done that Dave
Ramsey was gonna cost me my marriage
horse crap seriously now our marriage is
important absolutely our special needs
important yes absolutely as an option
important oh yes nothing's more
important than kids I got grandkids that
might be the only thing that's more
important than kids I'll just tell you I
kept fire we kept Rachel's to this
weekend I got a nine-month-old and Papa
Dave had a blast this weekend if I don't
know how great grandkids are gonna be
I'd have been nicer to their parents
seriously I am NOT saying these are not
valid noble callings they are the most
valid the most noble callings what I am
saying is is that your decision-making
paradigm breaks down when you start
saying stupid stuff and when I start
saying stupid stuff and I have said it
too like I was forced to do this or my
child is going to be in the street I had
to do $84,000 in the credit card debt to
pay the attorneys or I was going to lose
the custody battle maybe there's another
way to skin the cat maybe I don't have
to buy $45,000 SUV for my children to be
safe in a vehicle
maybe I can rent mouse maybe I don't
have to buy the $38,000 International
Adoption bill which is too much to pay
for an international adoption
maybe I start searching out some other
options to my decision other than one
that's good for the children and one and
that's financially stupid or one was
where we abandoned the children and it's
financially smart so Dave you wouldn't
have his trade money for children would
you no I really wouldn't but you're not
gonna put me in that false dichotomy
that false box that in causes me to
ensure your stupidity I've been there
I've done stupid stuff in the name of
nobility and my drama queen
four-year-old self inside of me told me
it was the only way to do it and let me
tell you when you make those kinds of
financial decisions they set you back a
decade and it does more harm to your
family than the thing you were trying to
protect your family from because you end
up working all the time just to pay
bills that you couldn't afford to take
out because you bought crap you made
mistakes with money you could not afford
to make and if you are sitting there and
you are hearing me say choose children
over money you are not listening and you
are a drama queen
right now you're living in drama queen
mode if you're hearing that right now
I'm not saying that I am saying see none
of the above a pick money B pick the
nobility of family and children over
money and makes a make a stupid decision
I'm saying see none of the above find
another way to skin the cat find another
way to make the decision find another
way to serve your family and maybe late
make less progress financially but not
justify rationalize with your
four-year-old self on a cereal aisle a
major stupid financial decision that's
going to set you back a decade or two
buying crap you can't afford and
rationalizing it with the nobility of
your family will take you to your knees
financially and keep you there your
children are not going to die if they
sleep in the same bedroom your children
are not going to die if there's only one
television in the house for them to
watch
your children are not going to die dot
dot dot I grew up in a 1000 square foot
home and I made it just fine and it was
a great home by the way think about this
most families in 1960 had one car of
course there was no internet and you
could not pull something out of your
pocket and order something from anywhere
around the world be delivered to units
about in two days either which is
nothing wrong with modern conveniences
but the point is folks our lifestyles
are quadruple what they were in 1970 the
quality of life that we have is way up
and yet we go into drama-queen mode and
justify expensive purchases or dumb
purchases that we cannot afford in the
name of some nobility and there was
another way to be Noble and take care of
that child there was another way to be
Noble and take care of that marriage
because we used to do it without those
purchases how did we how did we make it
before air bags I don't know I used to
sleep in the back window of the car and
when they slammed on the brakes we
rolled into the floor y'all remember
that anybody old enough well I'm not
saying you know that's kind of dangerous
well yeah but I mean we survived it not
suggesting we go back there but this
idea that your child is gonna
automatically die if you don't have a
brand new car with side window airbags
give me a break seriously especially for
a short term if you live like no one
else later you get to live and give like
no one else I just don't want to give up
to that much of them at time with my
family well maybe there's another way to
spend time with your family maybe when
you're spending time with your family
you turn off the television actually
spend time with your family oh there's a
neat idea see we we drama queen this up
and we use a noble calling which are
valid nobility call it not valid no
callings nothing invalid about the
calling invalid way to accomplish the
calling devastating our family
financially with this rationalization
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]